Eric simikis is going to talk in terms
of just a few of these qualities like
the hot the cold the wet and the dry and
notice he talks about some that are
taste perceptions the sweet and the
bitter bad love is when these things
actually jar with each other
when they don't get along when the
elements are out of accord with each
other good love is when they can be
brought into harmony with each other
let's say we get away from elements like
earth air fire water that sort of thing
and we think about parts of our body how
many of you are feeling particularly
good today
Olivia
how many of you feel sick maybe you feel
sick wow
there must be something going around
that's not good that means I'm probably
going to get sick too
how many of you are sort of in between
and what is treatment for Eric semicus
it's
reintroducing
good love
into the body